I've been called a lot of things from the mouths of 10, and 11 and 12-year-olds.
I also tell them, "Sometimes you're in school longer than you're actually at home."
Yeah.
And I tell them the same thing.
"I spend more time with you than I spend with my own family."
What?
Are you kidding me?
Dear Miss Coy.
I came into fifth grade as a shy girl...
...who especially struggled with talking in front of people.
You took an interest in the things that were important to me,...
...always asked about my family and showed an interest in my love of baseball.
Because of your teaching, you have inspired me to do whatever my passion is when I grow up.
I remember whenever I got stuck on a problem and I thought I just couldn't do it,...
...you said it's not that I couldn't do it, I just couldn't do it yet.
Thank you for making me a better person and thank you for never giving up on me...
....and helping me become the man I am today.